[Music]
[Applause]
how's it going bros my name is beer how
the Panch
hi fighting hired it oh wait sorry I'm
recording it wrong because this isn't
imagining all right
should it be better now are you better
now bro rah rah rah rah
I'm recording a 60 F ah god damn alright
whatever
let's just go hmm all right Dolph dolls
are good
I love dolls hello girl why hi it's only
girl okay is it there I saw something I
saw
oh no it's flying garbage oh god damn it
my mark huh oh [ __ ]
no it's the return of the oh now the
doll that's that good for huh don't know
don't scare me like that all right
I don't even know where are we gonna go
I don't understand why we just don't
leave this place
but Ken has his own stuff in mind I
don't even know anymore how a plan a PT
so we're gonna go here and not look at
the plants because plants are bad news I
hate Palance right it looks like we
can't go here because apparently it's
fine impossible to climb and shits you
know and there's garbage flying and
stuff too so that's never good news
anyway I'm gonna stay you know
and the one in here
I need to get out oh look at this it's
like oh I like it I want to decorate hey
darling I'm gonna be so happy once I
finish this game like I could I never
have to play this [ __ ] shitty controls
ever again I'm planning to play calling
after this one so hopefully and you used
to Remo store and I the num lock or
whatever [ __ ] it's called I actually
have one of those set up so I could use
sad but I don't know I don't know
whatever they did when they set up these
controls I they were drunk or hey what's
going on plants are you doing this girl
Wow
oh no oh it's like crazy [ __ ] again I
don't know
hi he's right here isn't he no no that's
not good for anyone
now the lights are off no no no we're
gonna make out I don't care what you do
Jesus crazy desperate I don't want ya oh
no oh no oh no it's oh oh alright okay I
ain't got my face that would cap oh
Jesus Christ
follow it yes run away from that stupid
girl and that stupid cat all right
oh god it's a dead him oh gosh Dedham
she's right behind me she oh oh no she's
comedy water okay that's Oh
oh good now that's healthy you're not a
dolphin I told you man
it doesn't oh I'll go now you're not a
freaking power even though that is not
your H that's for sure all right jump
all right we get stupid crazy [ __ ]
Donna
oh yeah she's gone she's gone we're safe
buddy
ha plants a penny it's time we go home
and see your mom or whatever
yep see ya - that was our Father
[Applause]
hey hey oh all right I cleared that
episode that was the third episode who
ain't that out a doomed a new kind of
cat wait I restarted what you put such a
hospital I am nothing scares you nothing
ever touches you you're called high are
they talking about my penis and
miss Kay unfeeling Island heart will
never be affected by those that have you
yeah that's me and we didn't find this
stupid items so oh it's still here cool
I thought someone said maybe it's a
fifth level though I thought someone
said you need to collect all the items
too
do something I don't know I only
recorded for five minutes I'm on a cell
phone she knew hey I love your Maps
oh no I'm at my computer you noodles and
[ __ ] oh I'm a cop
this sounds interesting for us everyone
says that the last one is the best one
sir oh god oh no I hate the security
camera have you seen that in a movie
that freaked me out as hell man I
remember I watched that in the world I
was like nope no she did not
oh man I seriously had nightmares after
nice oh good they look who's that but I
have my ramen her skin let me just grab
my ramen no you're doing it wrong
that's not the ramen what did i ah step
how's the hats gonna help Jesus Christ
like if she counts you could just throw
ramen at her my picture what do you want
ya know you bring a hat Jesus Christ
they're so stupid sometimes
I'm serious different white hey can't
can't
I'm gonna call it Kenan I don't know
your name it rolls much smoother not
100% Jesus penis usually it's like at
50%
okay all right I'm just gonna go out
nothing suspicious undersheriff someone
head out are you there good there's no
one here all right I am hey I see you
all right I'm just kidding yeah so we're
gonna do our little switch you switch
switch the thing about using the mouse
whenever I click go forward it goes to
the center do you see it that's why it's
so difficult that it doesn't do that on
the Wii modes but the Wemo I have to sit
for wheel back and I have to do yeah
trust me this is better bro all right
touch me touch me I'm just kidding I
would never do that face against you
I'm just kidding but there's a security
camera that doesn't blame you this late
well I gotta go do something about the
power first it took the phones anything
about the phones here ah ah I see uses
your memory
it reminds me of here the guy from
heroes yeah I think you'd wanna come
over our or something is that heroes I
don't remember it's a long time ago i
watch that ok girl but no are you crazy
baby did you do that I told you a
million times to push the boxes but what
does he do he pushes him hey what's that
oh that's not creepy
good huh Jesus Christ what are you doing
what are you doing you're doing it wrong
what is dance oh no already oh no I
ain't yep
can't get rid of face no oh oh it's just
an illusion of course god damn I want to
kick her in the face
I wanna kick your face just like BAM I'm
where the foot I did it effect with my
foot but you can't see my feet soon all
right whatever
we're just gonna go here how it girls
eyes and everything
Oh golden boy that sounds pretty nice
golden war really Golan Thor whatever
let's just go
the Golan we can't go into Golden Door
browse whatever I never liked golden
anyway so it's okay
pakhi Golan door I'm just gonna go over
here all right
if you drove on you can tell me how many
episodes there are like if there's four
or five hey what are you
I said Cat Cat just get out of here I
don't care about you anymore he's like
hey I'm naked follow me yay like no I
don't care your [ __ ] cat I hate cats
I don't hate cats hey boys would pretend
to be cash
oh no that's just wrong hey God come
back I'm gonna kick you in the face
that'd be awesome
Oh No God the [ __ ] sound starts again
blood its period I guess it's that time
a mosque for that lady but Jesus Christ
you two should wear out
I almost a diaper I don't know what it's
calling him English temple maybe it
would work with a diaper too if you
think about it I mean shouldn't judging
just because it's a diaper
I'm just saying I'm just I mean helpful
he's crying hey it's that no it's a good
kitty cat no it's just it man I would be
just so creeped out my face was but I
don't know I don't know I don't even
know anymore all right
what's going on here more period there's
more period I'm gonna be upset
discussion it oh this is creepy
it's just kids painting I like the kids
petting zoos all right
that's okay that's all right I'm reading
kitsch paintings all night that's the
best song ever
oh no I'm running out of batteries this
is not good I need a fire to fudge up
all right let's go to here wow hey kitty
cat hey cute cat tree KitKat I know
you're getting you're stepping by Jesus
Christ all right
Wow oh it's back the sounds back I get
it I get it you don't like me it's okay
that's okay we can cooperate all right
oh no I'm out of batteries so [ __ ]
soon come on batteries please please
please please be here yes there we go
there's something come on come on come
on hurry hurry it's so close yes Oh bro
that was pretty frakkin frak
yes I did say frigate of fragment Frank
you better believe it
hey who smoked yeah it's not allowed in
my disguise stupid kid painting my
office - scram so much
all right come on bro
anyway that's pretty much all the time I
had today hope you guys enjoyed
like favorite know that kind of stuff
subscribe if you haven't already if you
want to become a bro J and I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
I just came from that it's impossible
why am I talking like Stephane oh Carlos
I don't like word Arles misny